MIKE: Check out
this little bridge.
There's the building
right there, baby.
FRANK: It's big.
[honks horn]
MIKE: Hey-hey!
BOB: Hi, there.
MIKE: Hey, you Bob?
BOB: I am.
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
BOB: Hi, Mike.
MIKE: Nice to meet you.
This is Frank.
FRANK: Hey, Bob,
how're you doing?
I'm Frank.
BOB: Doing good, Frank.
MIKE: Hit him with the flyer,
Frankie.
FRANK: Here's some of the stuff
that maybe Danielle
went over with ya.
MIKE: How many years did
your dad work at Ford?
BOB: Uh, pretty much all of
his life, so since he was 18.
BOB: My dad was an engineer
for Ford Motor Company,
vehicle development.
MIKE: I can see right here,
you've got gas pumps,
so gas pumps is on there.
BOB: Yep,
I think there is pumps.
FRANK: Advertising.
MIKE: Any kind of advertising...
BOB: Yeah, there's
a few signs in here.
MIKE: How long was
your dad collecting?
Was he collecting
his whole life?
BOB: Pretty much
his entire life.
BOB: My dad was really
drawn to anything
that was related to Ford
and the automotive industry.
BOB: Unfortunately, he passed
away when he was 50 years old.
MIKE: Oh, wow.
BOB: And it's taken the family
25 years now to kind of say,
"Hey, this stuff
really needs to go."
BOB: Everything in that barn
has remained untouched
for the past 25 years,
because my dad put it there,
and disturbing that would be
almost like
disturbing his memory.
MIKE: Well, I'm glad
that you guys are at the point
where you're gonna start
selling some stuff,
because all of these things will
mean so much to other people.
MIKE: I can understand why
it's taken him this long
to want to move forward
with the collection.
I mean, this is
his father's space.
MIKE: What's this one?
This is a sign I dug out
from over there.
Here's the cool thing,
look it.
You can just see
"Pennsylvania..." something
"made gas."
But look...
BOB: What's that?
MIKE: This, this is cut off.
BOB: Oh.
MIKE: So this was
a longer sign at one time.
BOB: So they repurposed it.
MIKE: Yeah, they
repurposed it, exactly.
The killer thing,
is that it's wood,
it's hand-painted,
and it's gasoline 25 cents.
That's the biggie.
BOB: It's nice.
MIKE: Um...
200.
BOB: 200?
MIKE: That's kind of where
I feel I need to be on it.
You know what I mean?
BOB: Uh...
Would you...
give me two and a quarter?
♪
MIKE: I'm gonna do it.
BOB: Great.
MIKE: I'm doing it.
MIKE: Thank you very much,
I appreciate it.
BOB: Thank you, Mike.
FRANK: Hey, Bob?
BOB: Yeah, Frank.
FRANK: Check that out.
BOB: Ooh.
FRANK: I mean, you see Pepsi
coolers, you see Dr. Pepper...
BOB: Yep.
FRANK: ...7-Up.
But you don't see ginger ale.
Um, if I remember right,
this came out of Detroit.
It's missing the spout
on this side,
but I mean,
it's a great advertising piece.
Would 100 buy it?
BOB: Uh...
Can you do 125?
FRANK: 115.
BOB: 115.
FRANK: Deal?
BOB: Deal.
FRANK: Thanks, buddy.
BOB: I'm really glad to have
Mike and Frank come out
and see my father's collection.
I feel better than good,
I feel excited
that there's the opportunity
for someone
to enjoy it like my dad did.